tenemos una ecuación lineal y sabemos
que cuando x es igual a 4 entonces ya es
igual a 9 muy bien y lo hemos graficado
en esta línea aquí está el punto 49 muy
bien también sabemos que si x es igual a
6 si x es igual a 6 que es igual a 1 y
también lo hemos graficado por aquí así
que la línea verde representa todas las
soluciones a esta ecuación lineal que
todavía no conocemos lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es justamente definir esa
ecuación lineal y expresarla de dos
formas en su forma punto pendiente y en
la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
así que como siempre te invito a que
hagas una pausa y trates de resolver
este problema por tu propia cuenta
ok entonces vamos primero a generar la
forma punto pendiente ok y esta forma es
muy fácil de generar si sabes un punto
de la línea que de hecho aquí nos dan
dos verdades entonces tenemos esa
información y también necesitamos la
pendiente así que necesitaríamos
calcular la pendiente a partir de estos
dos puntos verdad tenemos dos puntos que
son soluciones de esa ecuación que no
conocemos hay que calcular la pendiente
ok entonces la pendiente se calcula de
forma muy fácil vamos a hacer entonces
primero la forma punto pendiente
punto pendiente muy bien entonces la
pendiente se calcula fácilmente verdad
simplemente hay que calcular la
pendiente que hay entre estos dos puntos
verdad simplemente tenemos que calcular
el cambio en y dividirlo entre el cambio
en x verdad entonces pensemos cuál es el
cambio en el cambio que tenemos
digamos partimos de este punto y la
altura es 9 y terminamos en este punto
de abajo que es el 1 verdad
a esta altura digamos entonces el cambio
en que sería el segundo menos el primero
bien tendríamos 1 menos
29 y esto va dividido entre el cambio en
x entonces cuál es el cambio en x pues
nosotros tenemos que pasar de 4 a 6
verdad entonces simplemente escribimos 6
verdad es el segundo menos 46 menos 4
verdad eso son esa es la forma de
calcular los cambios en nuestras
variables entonces esto es muy fácil de
calcular verdad 1 - 9 es menos 8 y 6
menos 4 32 y este menos nos está
diciendo porque es que la línea está
digamos inclinada
hacia la digamos tiene esta forma verdad
que si nos movemos hacia la derecha
bajamos justamente por este signo menos
entonces menos 8 dividido entre 2 es
igual a menos 4 y aquí ya hemos
calculado la pendiente que tiene esta
recta y por supuesto la pendiente es la
misma si consideramos cualesquiera dos
puntos verdad entonces lo importante fue
que calculamos el cambio en verdad el
cambio recordemos que se pone con una
letra griega delta verdad y esto fue
menos 8 y el cambio en x fue 2 verdad
tenemos esos cambios entonces la forma
punto pendiente vamos a poder llegar a
ella y de hecho lo voy a hacer a partir
de la definición de pendiente verdad por
ejemplo si tomamos un punto arbitrario x
que digamos posee este punto ese punto
debe satisfacer lo siguiente que ya
-9 verdad -9 fijémonos en fijémonos en
este punto justamente el 49 muy bien
entonces la pendiente debería ser
exactamente la misma si tomamos
cualquier punto verdad entonces de menos
9 sería un cambio en y dividido entre x
menos 4 verdad eso sería calcular la
pendiente que hay entre el punto x
y el punto 49 verdad pero está pendiente
ya la calculamos eso es igual a menos 4
muy bien entonces esto implica si por
ejemplo pasamos multiplicando el x 4 es
decir multiplicamos de ambos lados por x
4 vamos a obtener que ye menos 9 menos 9
es igual a menos 4 que multiplica a x
menos 4 muy bien y ahora si esta es la
forma punto pendiente verdad y esto fue
muy fácil porque tenemos un punto que
pasa por esa línea
el valor de la pendiente verdad la
pendiente es justamente menos 4 muy bien
ahora a partir de esto vamos a obtener
la forma pendiente ordenada al origen y
simplemente vamos a desarrollar esta
expresión muy bien entonces qué es lo
que tenemos tenemos menos 9 es igual a y
bueno desarrollamos la expresión de la
derecha y esto sería menos 4 x x perdón
sería menos 4 por equis y está menos 4x
y menos 4 x menos 4 que sería más 16
ahora si sumamos déjenme bajar un poco
esto si sumamos 9 de ambos lados que y
sumamos 9 de ambos lados que es lo que
obtenemos del lado izquierdo tenemos ya
y del lado derecho tendremos menos 4x y
aquí sí hay que hacer la operación 16 9
25 + 25 y esta es la forma justamente
que queremos verdad recordemos que la
forma pendiente ordenada al origen es de
este estilo y igual a mx + b donde m es
la pendiente y b es la altura verdad de
donde cruza por el eje y muy bien
entonces aquí ya obtuvimos justamente de
esa forma tenemos nuevamente que la
pendiente es menos 4 y eso ya lo
habíamos obtenido y ahora nos dicen más
información que la ordenada al origen se
encuentra en 25 es decir que la recta
cruza por el eje y en 0,25 verdad 0,25
esta es la forma pendiente
pendiente ordenada ordenada al origen
ordenada al origen y de hecho ya lo
habíamos visto en un vídeo anterior ok
entonces vemos que la recta crece mucho
si nos movemos hacia la izquierda verdad
de hecho aquí para para que cruce el eje
sería hasta 25 que quizás no se pasa de
incluso de la pantalla verdad no
alcanzaría a verse pero sí sabríamos que
intersecta al eje en en una altura de 25
ok entonces nosotros pudimos expresar
esta línea digamos con dos formas
distintas esencialmente una fue punto
pendiente que es esta de aquí y la otra
es pendiente ordenada al origen espero
te haya parecido interesante